[Music]
hey
i need you to acquire something only me
no client so i expect quick and clean
results
you will be entering tiger call
territory
very high risk more information attached
for the love of uh what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] style wasn't slumming it in squats
like your old
thing sure when i was scared out beyond
all recognition
mr stud all night
everyone don't be soft
upgrade now
well well well secret doors
how cliche why do peeps have to be so
goddamn predictable
must be connected to those doors or a
[ __ ] or flushing somewhere
who knows
looks like leia went to the tiger claws
behind what goes back to
claws aren't the deal honoring type
let's see if she got lucky
next
after the break we take a closer look at
the newspapers from avonte that hit
night city shells
[Music]
you could tomorrow do this
nothing and nobody stopping me one way
other i get what i want
[Music]
[Music]
hmm reminds me of this one diving arroyo
we used to sometimes
sideways
[Music]
both you and i know
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
i see you were able to find the knock
breaker
splendid work keep it up crossing